so have you have you seen a segway
before
i have seen that you've seen one before
apparently most people have said oh
that's the thing george bush fell off
and apparently he fell off it because he
hadn't switched it on but when you've
switched it on it's impossible to fall
off and i think they're i think they're
really good have either if you've ridden
on one before
no i haven't do you want to have a go go
ahead it's really it's really quite easy
so just put both feet put both feet up
get on with both feet and just relax
that's right now don't let it just
just stand there don't don't let it fall
don't fight it just
okay
it's a nice balance
symbol we're talking about today is
omega and i'll just write omega on this
piece of paper that's home ago that's
the lowercase uh greek symbol omega and
in mechanical engineering we use omega
to represent uh speed of rotation rate
of rotation so when things are rotating
uh omega is that is what we use
and
omega is really important having sensors
that can detect rate of rotation are
really important and uh we can use those
uh to help help control balance the oh
the unit the omega is expressed in
radians per second and a radiant a
radian is an angle and you'll probably
remember from uh from school that a
radian is defined as being the angle
it's it's that angle there
where the distance along the arc
is the same as the radius so rate of
rotation is measured in radians per
second so how many of those angles you
turn go through per second so that's
rate of rotation if something's going
around a thousand revs a minute revs per
minute is the speed is the thing most
people are familiar with like they'll
all have a rev counter on the car and
you know you might see that when you and
your engine's idling it's going around
at uh 800 revs a minute if you divide by
10 that gives you radians a second
roughly so 800 revs a minute when your
car engine's idling is about 80 radians
per second and if you're bombing down
the motorway and doing 4 000 revs a
minute that's about 400 radians per
second in terms of the rotation of your
your car engine now actually we're
extremely we're extremely clever
humans are and inside our ears we've got
some rotation rate of rotation uh
sensors and they're called semicircular
canals and i don't know if you can see
this picture here but many of you will
have heard of the of the uh the
semicircular canals in our ears and what
they are they're sort of there's some
semicircular tubes full of liquid when
your head starts to move
uh in in one of three planes the uh
the liquid inside the tube stays where
it is the tubes move and some little
apparently some tiny hairs inside the
semi-canals detect the movement of this
liquid and know that you're rotating so
they're measuring so these semicircular
canals in your ears measure rate of
rotation and people often experience
that if they have an ear infection or
something they lose their balance
and two of my colleagues uh
uh i've been working on these sorts of
sensors for for many years they're not
at university at the moment but they've
done some work um
developing gyroscopic sensors gyroscopes
can detect uh rate of rotation and they
develop some special
miniature gyroscopic sensors that can
detect rate of rotation and they did
some work with bae systems and developed
these gyroscopic sensors they're known
as rotating ring
sensors and you can see the size of them
here compared to the the size of this
pencil but the a really interesting
application with this is in the segway
and i don't know whether you've heard of
the uh the segway the segway was a um
a transporting device that's been
developed uh in america oh well actually
i have to have one here in my office so
just come over here uh brady and you can
see we have a segway in my office as you
can see they've got two wheels
and you uh of course if i just let go
the thing will fall over
you can hear the everything coming into
action
now it's got some it's got these uh rate
of rotation sensors these the gyroscopic
sensors and
they detect the rate of rotation
and control the wheel so if it's moving
forward they'll move the wheel slightly
forward to make you make you make your
balance
and if i stand on it now
it's uh it's balancing for me what kind
of rate rates of rotation for omega are
we looking at on a machine like this
well these will be these were very small
because obviously we're not
when this thing starts to rotate
forwards it's not rotating at thousands
of revs a minute these will just be
probably fractions of a radian per
second
you might say i'll just lock my office
up and
we'll have to go down the it doesn't go
down the stairs very well
look how dizzy you're on camera we've
got brady behind you sorry there's brady
here
filming me so you're on camera
okay it'll be here do you want to go
downstairs
yeah okay
it's very maneuverable it'll turn around
on a sixpence so when i'm in the lift i
can uh i can turn around and come out
forwards again
right so we've come down i've turned
around now so we can go outside and uh
and give it take it for a while
all right we've got a trip hazard here
this morning but we should be able to
get over that all right
oh no we'll be able to go over that all
right
there we go it's got uh it's got
pneumatic tyres so it's it's quite good
on rough ground it's got its batteries
and the control system the gyroscopes in
the control system uh underneath
underneath my feet and there are five
gyroscopes to detect uh rotation
uh about the wheels and also uh uh
rotation uh
uh about the vertical axis as well oh
yeah a lot of people look enviously and
won't have a go on it so uh and
sometimes i'll let them have a go but
not not often so have you have you seen
a segway before
i have seen that you've seen one before
apparently most people have said oh
that's the thing george bush fell off
and apparently he fell off it because he
hadn't switched it on but when you
switch it on it's impossible to fall off
and just relax
that's right now don't let it just
just stand there don't don't let it
don't fight it just let it balance for
you right
okay now um
no i'm going to let go in a minute don't
worry
lean very slightly towards me
no that's right
that's right a little it'll move slowly
towards me
and then if you lean lean back a bit
it'll stop
and if you lean slightly backwards it'll
just lean very slightly backwards to
move backwards
now
can can you
can you feel that it's keeping you in
balance it's quite a funny sensation
isn't it just lean forward and do
everything very gently that's right
what's that feeling like it is quite
good
okay
it's a nice balance
that's right yes
how fast
you can see this little
there's a little there's a little
tortoise symbol on there that means it's
speed is limited to four miles an hour
so
you're okay
it will go to 12 miles an hour but
that's uh you need to have the uh
you need to have your helmet on for that
she's doing extremely well i think she's
a natural
[Laughter]
so you just have to step back with one
foot first and i'll hold it and then
you'll be all right
yes
it was great i loved it we should have
more of them yeah that's right yes they
cost four grand if you want to buy your
own
so that's probably why people haven't
more many people have bought them